it's time for our seen an unseen segment
where we expose the big cultural stories
of the day elites targeting you in
America hollywood's georgia boycott
Olbermann takes on the south and two
states don't want to eat chick-fil-a
joining us now all the details Raymond
Arroyo Fox News contributor a New York
Times bestselling author of the brand
new book will Wilder the amulet of power
all right Raymond why are the Hollywood
do-gooder elites now trying to mess with
the Georgia Laura Georgia is poised to
pass what they call the heartbeat bill
now this would forbid abortions at about
six weeks once a fetal heartbeat is
detective well actress Alyssa Milano
who's shooting a Netflix series in
Georgia has gotten a hundred actors to
sign a letter threatening to boycott the
state if it passes the heartbeat law
they include Alec Baldwin Amy Schumer
Marc Garofalo and others Milano even
held a presser at the Georgia State
House with about 30 co-workers watch
we'd like to remind you that government
is never bigger than when it's inside a
woman's body or in her doctor's office
I've never seen a government inside a
woman's body but we'll check on that
okay Milani should have a hard way yeah
I don't know Milano tried to deliver her
ultimatum to the governor who was not in
but she did run into a Republican
representative Dominic Lorie cheer watch
there's 30 people outside that do both
in Georgia don't interrupt well the
congressman asked the right question
Laura what district are you from now the
state of Georgia gives away three
hundred million dollars or so annually
to the film income tax breaks and this
is the thanks they get bullying from the
very people benefiting from their
generosity Laura do you know the
government of Georgia has never done a
cost-benefit analysis for the 300
million dollars they give away each year
to Hollywood if they do that they might
find they're not making as much as
they're giving out what would they
possibly do in Georgia without Sean Penn
traipsing around ELISA who's the boss
I'll tell you who the boss is is Trump
in another act of southern harassment
Keith Olbermann ESPN anchor forever
article in a local Mississippi newspaper
and it told the story of Hunter Waltman
a hunter who successfully tracked and
killed a rare white turkey it's so
enraged Oberman that he tweeted it'd be
rare and beautiful so me should kill it
this pea-brained scumbag identifies
himself as hunter Waltman and we should
do all our best to make sure the rest of
his life is a living hell and the nitwit
clown who wrote this fawning piece
should be fired well this led to threats
against the hunter and the paper how
does open think slice turkey gets to his
ball du cheese does it slice itself in
the wild he had to apologize and he is
officially the worst person in the world
actually yep alright now these elites
are even trying to tell us what we can
and cannot eat of course they're not
happy and they always want government or
out of a woman's body they want to
affect what goes in our body okay
chick-fil-a has been barred from
establishing restaurants at two airports
in Buffalo Niagara Airport in San
Antonio now this is because of the
complaints alleged against the company's
alleged stance on LGBT issues not an
issue to kick chick-fil-a out of San
Antonio this is about making public
spaces available to everybody I think
you should have the right
laughs and marry whoever you want but I
don't think it would be enough for me to
prevent me from going into I check for
life
I like their food now Laura it's one
thing if consumers want to decide I'm
not going to go into that restaurant or
that particular store because of the
political viewpoint of the store I guess
we're gonna have to post it like calorie
count up on the menu yeah but for the
government to ban a restaurant seems way
over the top this is the beginning of
something much bigger censorship it's a
central government federal government oh
now we're only gonna have certain
restaurants for our for conservatives I
guess in certain I guess that's how they
want to play it oh yeah it's bad for
America before we go I have to share
this with everyone this is a picture I
watched this taking place now this is
you and Joe Biden at a party many years
ago ah as I watched by and give his may
a culpa today I thought about this do
you remember he walked up to you he put
both his hands on your shoulders and he
said honest-to-god Angra Ham of all the
right-wingers you're my favorite
honester guy watch this do you remember
this it was to build you up lor
my career always tried to make a human
connection I say kids I hug people I I
grab men and blue my shoulders is that
you can do this well I'm honest to god
Ingram you're my favorite favorite host
not Shannon Perrine I hope that Tucker's
you baby not here can you read your
chance